fabienne elle nicole
solutionner le problème de la condition
humaine par la force les conquêtes par
la sagesse l'écran règne par l'amour le
christianisme par les opium autant
d'échecs
mais aujourd'hui la science nous propose
la loi de la statistique des machines
cybernétique pourraient être des
gouvernants bien plus impartiaux que le
meilleur des âmes vasarely bon gardien
nous souhaitons vous faites moins de
limites même s'il ya quelque chose parce
que les filles ça passe ça ça métro ça
fait amicaux faut pas que ça se fait
mais les causes de l'infestation jason
bay tous les gestes saccadés sais pas je
vais pas sur une scène qui vend donc ça
pouvait durer sept îles
oui solutionner le problème de la
condition humaine par la farce dans les
conquêtes par la sagesse dans les grands
règne par l'amour le christianisme par
les opium autant d'échecs
mais aujourd'hui la science de propose
la loi de la statistique des machines
cybernétique pourraient être des
gouvernants bien plus impartiaux que le
meilleur des hommes vasarely
test
ah ah ouais
notre ami john mack arctique et
professeur à l'université de treand ford
poursuit ses recherches dans le domaine
de l'intelligence artificielle
attention les sages les robots vous
rattrape le nouvel avis tech nous avons
ce soir est un chercheur bien sûr qui
cherche sa voie entre les scènes de
théâtre et la biochimie macromoléculaire
sur la scène son nom et georges balle
mais entre nous nous l'appelons docteur
dr balla ça j'aime beaucoup vous parler
mais certains pensent que je parle trop
certains chercheurs voudrais me
remplacer par une machine
c'est tout ce que je sais que ça
sur la lancée d'un faut viser l'or as
monaco et des carrières et de me dire
pourquoi vous aimez les sciences
mais ça veut
moi j'ai une science parce que la
science c'est quand même
franchement ça n'est pas quelque chose
qui vous vient à l'esprit
mambé des transports
où
moi j'aime les sciences je crois qu mais
les sciences dans le domaine de la
sécurité
le domaine quand on se perd dans les
méandres de la littérature ou de la
philosophie des problèmes d'une
difficulté d'une un peu d'assurance tout
le monde peut assurer n'importe quoi
alors que les sciences sont là avec leur
pivot rassurant leurs preuves
leur identification leur vérification
dans tous les domaines leurs
applications extraordinaire tant dans la
science naturelle que dans les sciences
appliquées on s'y retrouve on retrouve
alors on se sent tout d'un coup plus
seul dans un univers qu'on ne comprend
pas un univers de phénomènes
contradictoires retrouve une ligne et
cette ligne si la science voilà pourquoi
j'aime les sciences
poses avantageuses
un pan tour des sciences
on a beaucoup parlé des femmes et de
leur goût pour la littérature pour la
littérature fantastique je n'y crois pas
ou alors ils cherchent là une fausse
féminité la véritable femme
la bêta féminité et scientifique elle
retrouve là un pivot une nécessité
quelque chose qui la justifient elles
mêmes
elle est alors allée reconnu dans le
domaine du fantastique de littérature de
la philosophie halle et se perd un peu
elle même dans le domaine de la science
on retrouve une spontanéité aussi
manche et de la mer
coupez